hey guys is going to be the quickest
vlog you've ever seen but I just wanted
to say there is a fan-made video that
you guys really really need to see and
I've been delayed on seeing it because
when I first opened it up pretty soon
after I hit 5 million there was a
special request for me to make a
reaction video to it but recently I lost
my internet which is why I'm not in my
apartment or my normal office that I
normally work out of and I really wanted
to make that but then I lost everything
and I got too late and Monday came
around in it's vlog day and you guys
need to see it here's a clip of it like
seriously don't sit around you have to
see it it's one of the coolest fan
creations to come out of this entire
community not that there haven't been
amazing ones but let's watch
instead
that was incredible and you guys can
check out the full video either by
clicking the link on the video you just
said clicking the annotation up there or
in the description below seriously thank
you guys so much it was amazing to see
and when I was finally watching it I I I
wish that I could have recorded it in
the beginning because it was just such
this weird feeling like oh my god
this is so much talent all in one place
and I can't imagine the logistics of
organizing it but seriously thank you
guys so much for 5 million and I know
it's already like 5.3 million now and
we're already rocketing to 6 million but
just thank you guys so much for being
the awesome creative people that I know
you can be so anyway that's the end of
this video five nights at Freddy's 3 is
coming but you all know that by now
according to the video I posted earlier
today but just thanks again everybody so
much for being the most awesome
community ever and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
we
we should